In the last video, we showed
that if you had a line, which
we'll call a directrix--
we draw the directrix.
That's our directrix and it has
the equation y is equal to k.
And you have a point, that's
our focus, and it's the
coordinate a comma b.
That the locus of all points in
the xy plane that are
equidistant to this focus and
this directrix has a shape that
looks something-- we know that
this was a point-- that
looks something like this.
And the actually equation, we
actually just took an arbitrary
xy in the coordinate plane, and
we said that xy has to satisfy
the condition that its distance
to this focus is equal to--
that this distance right here
is equal to this distance here.
And we set that up using the
distance formula to here, and
then setting that equal to the
distance to the line,
to the directrix.
And then we did a bunch of
algebra and we got this
equation right here.
For all of the points in the xy
plane that satisfy the
conditions that its distance to
the focus is equal to the
distance to this line.
And we hopefully satisfied
ourselves that this is
in fact a parabola.
And although it looks a little
bit hairier than most parabolas
we see, I think if you look
at it closely, you'll realize
that it is indeed a parabola.
For example, the classic
parabola is y is
equal to x squared.
How is this the same
thing as this?
Well in this case, this
coefficient out here
is just equal to 1.
So in this case, 1 over 2 b
minus k is equal to 1, right?
Let me delete that little
thing there, because it
looks like a squared.
All right, the coefficient
in front of the x squared
term is equal to a 1.
What is a equal to?
Well this is the same
thing-- actually, let
me rewrite it that way.
I could rewrite this equation
right here as y minus 0 is
equal to 1 times x
minus 0 squared.
And now hopefully you see that
this has the same pattern as
this, although the y's and the
x's are just sitting
on different sides
of the equation.
So here you see that the 1/2
over b minus k, that's the
coefficient in front of the
x minus a squared term.
So that's where we got that
that has to be equal to 1.
a has to be equal to
0 in this situation.
This curve right here is equal
to x squared, y is equal
to x squared, a is 0.
And then b plus k over 2, this
is going to be equal to that.
And keep in mind, I actually
swapped the left and
the right hand sides.
But this is y minus something,
this is y minus 0.
So this something has
to be equal to 0.
So you get b plus k
over 2 is equal to 0.
And now we should be able to
use this information to figure
out the actual coordinates of
the focus and the directrix of
what I would call the classic
parabola, y is equal
to x squared.
So keep in mind what we did.
In the last video, we said what
is the equation of the line
that is equidistant between
this focus and this directrix?
And we got this equation,
which we said, hey,
that's a parabola.
Now we're going the
other way around.
We say we have a parabola, and
we're saying that this parabola
is the set of all points that's
equidistant between some
focus and some directrix.
What is that focus and
that directrix for this
particular parabola?
That's what we're trying to do.
And the way we did that was, we
pattern matched this formula to
this one, to essentially set up
these variables, which
essentially define a focus
and a directrix, right?
b is the y-coordinate of the
focus, k defines the horizontal
line of the directrix.
So if we can solve for b and
k, we know what the focus
and the directrix are.
And for a, although
a is pretty easy.
So let's do that.
So if we know that 1 over 2
b minus k is equal to 1--
let me do that over here.
I'm going to do it in
particular for this case right
here, but you don't want to do
that every time, so then we'll
do a more general formula that
we can just plug in next time
you see a new parabola.
So if we multiply both sides of
this equation by 2 b minus k,
you get 1 is equal to
2 times b minus k.
Actually I should redivide both
sides by 2, so you get 1/2
is equal to b minus k.
Fair enough.
Let's see, this equation
right here, b plus k
over 2 is equal to 0.
That means that b plus k
must be equal to 0, right?
This numerator has
to be equal to 0.
So let me write that down.
b plus k is equal to 0.
Two linear equations
of to unknowns.
Let's add them up.
The k's cancel out.
You get 2b is equal to 1/2.
Divide both sides by 2, you
get b is equal to 1/4.
And now what's k?
Well, we can just
resubstitute back.
Let's use this equation.
We get 0 is equal
to 1/4 plus k.
You can figure that out by
inspection, but you can
subtract 1/4 from both sides.
So this tells us that k
is equal to minus 1/4.
So let's draw this.
So if this is my coordinate
axis-- I'll do it in
a different color.
That's the x-axis,
that's the y-axis.
We're dealing with y is equal
to x squared, which you should
hopefully be reasonably
familiar with at this point.
It's kind of the classic
U-shaped parabola that
looks just like that.
Let me write that down.
This is y is equal to x
squared, which we could have
rewritten as y minus 0 is equal
to 1 times x minus 0 squared.
Same thing, that's this line.
It's equidistant from a focus
and a directrix, where
this is the focus.
And how do I know that the
focus is right there, instead
of right here or right there?
Well one, you could kind
of think about it.
But the other thing to realize
is, what is the vertex
of this parabola?
And I think we've gone
over that already.
But the vertex are the
coordinates given by this
x value and this y value.
Or what x values make this
whole term 0 and make
this whole term 0?
And that's essentially 0,0.
So this is the vertex
of this parabola.
This is the vertex,
0,0 is the vertex.
I'll say v for vertex.
In an upward opening parabola,
you can view that as
the minimum point.
If it was a downward opening,
it would be the topmost
point, or the maximum point.
That's the vertex.
And we saw from when we solved
this, when we just did our
pattern matching, that the
x-coordinate of our focus is
equivalent to, if we just
pattern match right here, x
minus a squared, here you
have x minus 0 squared.
This is always going to
be the same as this.
So the x-coordinate of our
focus is always going to
be the same thing as the
x-coordinate of our vertex.
So we figured out that
a was equal to 0.
So the coordinate here is
0, and then what's b?
This was the coordinate 0,b.
We figured out that b is
equal to 1/4, 0, 1/4.
And then the directrix is
the line y is equal to k.
In this case, we figure out
k is equal to minus 1/4.
So our directrix is going
to be right down here.
Right down here, like that.
And it's going to be line
y is equal to minus 1/4.
And that first of all
looks about right.
And it also gels
with what we know.
Because this point right here,
our vertex, is equidistant,
it's 1/4 below our focus and
it's 1/4 above our directrix.
So at least that little
reality check holds.
But it's was a particular
circumstance, and you don't
want to have to go through this
whole situation every time you
have to figure out the focus or
the directrix of a parabola.
So let's see if we can come up
with a more general solution.
And actually what I'm
going to do is, I'm going
to erase all of this.
Just because I want to reuse
that, and I haven't committed
that formula to heart yet.
Let me erase all of this,
and erase all the work
we did down here.
So let's do a general form.
And actually, I've abused this
so much, let me rewrite it.
So I'll put the y's on the
left hand side, instead
of keep telling you that
I've switched them.
So this is the same thing as--
I'll do it in-- the color
choosing is the hard part.
I'll do it in this
light, off-white color.
So you get y minus b plus k
over 2 is equal to 1 over 2
times b minus k, times
x minus a squared.
This is the locus of all points
that are between the directrix,
y is equal to k-- well, they're
equidistant to the directrix,
y is equal to k, and
the focus a comma b.
So let's say that I
have a parabola.
And I'm going to try to
use different letters, so
we don't get confused.
I give you the
parabola y minus y1.
And let's say this parabola
has a vertex at x1 comma y1.
So this parabola I'm drawing
has a vertex right there.
So its formula will be y minus
y1 is equal to some constant,
let's make that a capital A.
This capital A is different
than that lowercase a.
This is what I was going to
embark on in the previous
video, and then I realized that
I was trying to load that video
up too much and probably
confusing you.
So some constant factor, some
type of scaling factor, times
x minus the x value
of our vertex.
So x1, all of that, squared.
So if you're given this
parabola, or if you can get a
parabola to this form, how do
you figure out the a's, the
b's, and the k's so you know
the coordinates of the
directrix and the focus?
So the easy thing is to figure
out a, because you just
do a pattern match.
This is going to
be equal to that.
So you know that a
is equal to x1.
So the x-coordinate of our
focus is the same as the
x-coordinate of our vertex.
You can pattern match that this
scaling factor right here is
going to be the same thing
as this 1 over 2 b minus k.
So let's write that down.
A is equal to 1
over 2 b minus k.
And then we have,
finally, this.
Let me do another color.
I'll do a magenta.
The b plus k over 2, we
have y minus that thing.
We have y minus y1.
So that's going to
be equal to y1.
So you have y1 is equal
to b plus k over 2.
And now we have two equations
with two unknowns.
Remember, this is
going to be a given.
The A is going to be given, and
the y1 is going to be given.
So now we can solve for
b and k in terms of the
numbers that we have.
So let's see if we can do that.
So if we multiply both sides of
this equation times b minus k,
you get b minus k times
A is equal to 1/2.
Divide both sides by A,
you get b minus k is
equal to 1 over 2A.
And on the right hand side,
let's use this other
formula right here.
If we multiply both sides by
2-- I'll use a different
color-- you get 2 times
y1 is equal to b plus k.
Two equations with
two unknowns.
Let's take this and bring it
down here, so you get b plus
k is equal to 2 times y1.
And so you add them, and you
get 2b is equal to-- the k's
cancel out; I'm just adding
these two equations--
1 over 2A plus 2 y1.
Or b-- which is,
remember, what was b?
That was the y-coordinate of
our focus-- is equal to, divide
everything by 2, is equal
to 1 over 4A plus y1.
Which is interesting.
It tells us that we take the
y-coordinate of our vertex
and we add 1 over 4A to it.
Which is exactly what
happened last time, right?
I actually erased what
I did last time.
But last time, when we
had y equal x squared,
this value was 0.
The scaling factor was 1.
So we saw that the y-coordinate
of our focus was 1/4.
So this is gelling
with what we know.
So that's our b.
And let's see if we
can solve back for k.
So we know that--
let's do it up here.
We know that 2 y1 is equal
to b, which is 1 over
4A plus y1 plus k.
We can subtract y1 from both
sides, so this goes away and
we just have a y1 there.
Subtract 1 over 4A from both
sides and you get y1 minus
1 over 4A is equal to k.
So then we are done.
So this is interesting.
Right now these might look
a little, these little
hairy formulas.
But if we actually graph it,
I think they'll become a
little bit more intuitive.
So once again, we had the
parabola y minus y1 is equal to
A times x minus x1 squared.
And so the graph of that
parabola will look
something like this.
I don't know where it is
relative to the x- and y-axis.
It will look
something like this.
It'll be this U shape.
It could actually be downward
pointing, but I'll just assume
an upward pointing
parabola for now.
That's this formula.
Its vertex, right there,
its vertex is the
point x1 comma y1.
Right?
What y value makes this
expression equal 0?
It's y1.
What x value makes
that equal 0?
It's x1.
Now notice, what is
this directrix?
It's the line ok, y equal to
k, but it's 1/4 less than
this value right here.
So you literally just go down
1/4-- not just 1/4, 1/4
times this scaling factor.
So it's 1/4 A.
This distance is 1/4 A.
And then you get your
directrix, right?
It's y1 minus 1/4 A is
equal to k. y1 minus
1/4 A is equal to k.
Or 1 over 4A.
So your directrix is
going to be right there.
Let me write this.
It's y is equal to y1,
which is just this
level, minus 1 over 4A.
But this is the intuitive part.
Just remember, you're going
1 over 4A below the vertex.
And then the focal point, the x
value of the focal point is
going to be x1, the same as
the x value of the vertex.
And then the y value is
just b, and we just go
1 over 4A above it.
Which makes sense because we
need to be equidistant from
the directrix and the focus.
So this is y1 plus 1 over 4A.
But the intuitive part is, we
just took 1 over 4A above it.
So in general, if I gave
you-- so just think
about this a second.
If I gave you an equation,
an arbitrary equation now.
Say, y minus 1 is equal to 2
times x minus 3 squared, we can
graph this and draw the focus
fairly-- and actually
it's foci, if there was
more than one focus.
Let's see, that's the
x-axis, that's the y-axis.
Where's its vertex?
The vertex is at the
point 3 comma 1.
So we go 1, 2, 3 comma 1.
So that's its vertex.
It's an upward opening
parabola, because this
is a positive number.
Actually, we don't even
have to know that.
If you just draw the focus and
the directrix, you might be
able to figure that out.
But where's the focus point?
The focal point is going to be
1 over 4A above this point.
So 1 over 4 times 2
is equal to 1/8.
So the focal point is
going to be really close.
It's going to be right up here.
It's going to be 1/8
above our vertex.
And then our directrix is
going to be 1/8 below it.
So it's going to
be right there.
The directrix is going
to look like this.
to be there, the
focal point is there.
And then the graph of this
parabola is going to look
something like this.
So anyway, hopefully I didn't
confuse you too much.
And the whole point of doing
all of this is just to realize
that it's pretty easy to find
the focus and the directrix of
a parabola if you have its
equation in this form.
You just take whatever is
multiplying times the x minus
whatever squared term.
And you essentially divide
1 by 4 times this value.
And then you know the distance
from the vertex to the focus,
and you know the distance from
the vertex to the directrix,
and you're all done.
See you in the next video.